since I was a kid I always loved Hillary
you know like I love accessories
I would say my mom with all these
accessories too and I just brought like
I grew up with it and we subject to on
debugging and I'm gonna show you someone
you Turing
I always got this curve this is like my
trademark you know managing Columbia it
was a friend of mine I wanted to have
this classic look like 80s and this is
like my style I'm almost with across you
know and I love it that thing is like
super retro right now I got this channel
earring and it looks like something that
you don't see real much from guys when
it comes to you know start or appearance
but I really travelled into channel is
the details you know maybe sometimes you
can see like it's a regular thing but
then you go and you see like what where
the CC is always a winner you know this
has leather here and so stones - what
section elke so I think it's differently
you don't see like this type of mix
between you know this black stone and
leather and just see details you know I
love it it is different
this lighting ball this one as you can
see that was in the floor
it's canary diamond but it really pops
out real where would the black on the
other side this is the sable about my
latest album and it here
like my whole crew all the people that
was related in the album not the
producer the mixer some writers they all
have this one they love it and that most
makes me happy it makes me more happy to
give than you know to get something this
place was made by Ben baller which is a
really like thing that one of the best
if not the best you know
either doing custom things so he's the
one who started out movement with the
colored stones and things like that with
Pharrell Williams back in the day
Pharrell it's like my mentor in this you
know he's been teaching me a lot about
everything and it's my biggest
inspiration when it comes to you Larry
you know because always was different
you know always we call her or something
that is like what was that does doesn't
go like I don't see nobody else killing
it on the you terrain like that and then
we have this one from Anil Hernandez
which is a gradual er from Europe and he
did this version with the color of the
label that member ID
[Music]
another one that we killed the game last
year was this Morikami piece when I come
is one of the oddities that I really
love
we even sank in this piece and he's
beautiful that even you know the mass
term were coming 181 say well I have one
more lie of course so we say he won us a
gift
he loves the one he'd seen it the inner
that went crazy with this piece with Ben
baller
Emeril's canary diamonds Ruby it's a
spinner and this one is the white one so
you know it's like a set I don't know my
mom doesn't let me say that this like is
a good link you know like the classic
butch link but it's super long and this
one is gradient it goes from white to
pink this is a big chain it's a diamond
in rubies but at the same time you wanna
like make a shorter so you just
disconnect it from here and then you go
up to change now
I used to be like crazy with rims all
over my hands like ten on ten and I'm
just like I'm chilling now I'm into a
lot of grills - there's some classic
ones you know like all iced out this is
the bottoms all white diamonds this is
the other ones it's like more or white
this rose gold and white diamond tanks I
never lost anything
I'm really responsible absolutely fact
all your ambassadors so all you can
share holders of course okay so this is
one of one this is beautiful like a
rainbow the work is just amazing how
they pull all these stones together it's
like classic but at the same time it has
this vibe right here
you know this classic color your
bracelets this one is different because
it has different stones like so why but
it has like rubies and all this
different stones that has on it it was
someone that I just went crazy together
bracelets from Cartier and then I'm like
nah better stop or I'll chill this one
was a gift from Allah so from here yeah
it's like so beautiful
you know the rainbow thing about uterus
like I do it for me you know I don't do
it to show enough to nobody you know
this is the first time I do something
about this is because GQ is so good we
got you I was born with different I grew
up in Colombia
let's say like we love to keep it on the
low we grew up in a cool way that we
don't like to show up we came from a lot
of bad things going on in Colombia we
learn how to be low-key here is a
different vibe so here we play the game
I'm grateful with God for all the
blessings but to me this is just
material things you gave me this is for
me it is not to show-off
you